Multiplica y simplifica
"x" al cuadrado menos raíz de 6 por "x" al cuadrado más raíz de 2 o sea nos piden multiplicar 2
polinomios de 2 términos ¡Vaya! Multiplicar 2
binomios, hay varias formas de hacer esto
en este video vamos a ver 2, una es una forma intuitiva que nada más utiliza la propiedad
distributiva de la suma con la multiplicación,
y la otra es una forma que se ve en clase que es un poquito más rápida
pero requiere un poquito de memoria.
Bueno vamos a empezar con la forma intuitiva y para esto déjame poner aquí la ley
distributiva "a" por "x" más "y"
es igual a ax, ax más ay.
Esto de aquí es la distributivad de la multiplicación con la suma ¿Vale?
¿Ok? Entonces vamos a usar esto acá, pero pensando que "x" cuadrada menos 6
es nuestra "a", es como nuestra "a"
entonces vamos a distribuirla en estos dos numeritos de aquí,
déjame ver qué nos queda, a ver "x" cuadrada menos 6 lo tenemos que poner acá,
"x" cuadrada menos raíz de 6 perdón, menos raíz de 6 va aquí,
eso tenemos que multiplicarlo por "x" al cuadrado
y tenemos que sumar, esto puede ser un poco
quizás no tan intuitivo, por que esta es una expresión grande ¿Verdad? Pero es
igualito que acá, simplemente la pensamos como "a" y lo distribuimos así, entonces sería más
eso mismo, "x" cuadrada menos raíz de 6,
por el segundo término que es raíz de 2, raíz de 2
Ahora la parte padre es que nada más tenemos que usar
distributividad otra vez ¿Cómo le hacemos ahora?
Ahora lo que nos gustaría es distribuir este "x" al cuadrado en estos 2 términos
y este raíz de 2 en estos 2 términos
¡Vaya! Estamos usando la distributividad pero ahora sí como "x" más "y"
por "a" es igual a ax
más ay, nada más estamos cambiando el orden de la operación,
así que no pasa nada ¿Vale? Entonces vamos a distribuir así y vamos a ver qué nos queda entonces,
"x" al cuadrado por "x" al cuadrado es "x" a la cuarta,
"x" a la cuarta, luego "x" al cuadrado por menos raíz de 6 es menos raíz de 6x cuadrada,
luego raíz de 2 por "x" cuadrada es más raíz de 2x al cuadrado
y luego sería -raíz de 2 por  raíz de 6.
Déjame hacerlo por aquí por separado para que quede más bonito.
Raíz de 2 por raíz de 6 es igual a,
pues esto es lo mismo que raíz de 2 por 6 que es igual a raíz de 12
Esto es utilizando propiedades de los radicales
entonces, nos queda menos raíz de 12 ¿Ok?
Ya con esto logramos multiplicar. Ahora hay que simplificar,
¿vale? Entonces para simplificar pues tenemos este "x" a la cuarta, "x" a la cuarta
que no hay ningún otro término de grado 4 entonces se queda solito, luego tenemos que juntar estos dos,
tenemos que ponerle por acá y aquí le voy a poner así, más y aquí voy a abrir paréntesis "x" cuadrada
entonces, ¿Qué nos quedaría aquí adentro? Sería raíz de 2 menos raíz de 6.
Otra vez aquí estamos aprovechando la propiedad distributiva ¿Verdad?
Si multiplicas te vuelve a quedar lo de aquí arriba,
y finalmente pues podríamos simplificar este raíz de 12 de la siguiente forma.
Raíz de 12 también es igual a raíz
de 3 por 4, que es raíz de 3 por raíz de 4, que es igual a 2 veces raíz de 3 por que
raíz de 4 es igual a 2 entonces, podemos poner este raíz de 12 como
menos 2 veces raíz de 3
¿Muy bien? Bueno de hecho se puede argumentar o debatir si la de arriba o la de abajo son más simples
pero bueno, ya multiplicamos
y simplificamos utilizando únicamente la propiedad
distributiva ¿Vale? No es nada nuevo no es nada demasiado sofisticado.
Ahora déjame ver otro método que se conoce como el método FOIL,
que viene de sus siglas en inglés
First out, bueno, Outer Inner y Last. Vamos a ver de qué se trata este método.
Básicamente es un algorítmo, a mí no me gusta mucho, no soy muy fan porque favorece la memorización.
En vez de entender una idea simple, que la propiedad distributiva
pero bueno, al menos el método FOIL si se asegura de que
multipliquemos todo lo que hay que multiplicar, y la idea es la siguiente.
La idea es la F quiere decir First, o sea los primeros términos, tenemos que multiplicar este con este
entonces, lo ponemos "x" cuadrada por "x" cuadrada es "x" cuarta ¿Va?.
Luego O es de Outer, tenemos que multiplicar los de afuera ¿Cuáles son los que quedan afuera?
Pues serían este "x" cuadrada con este raíz de 2 entonces, esa es la O.
Sería más raíz de 2x cuadrada, raíz de 2x cuadrada.
Luego I sería de Inner o sea los que están adentro.
Inner viene del inglés como adentro
entonces, tendríamos que multiplicar estos 2 déjame tomar el color amarillo, digamos
entonces estos 2 hay que multiplicarlos nos quedaría menos raíz de 6
"x" al cuadrado esta de ahí es la I y finalmente con color rojo voy a hacer la L que quiere decir Last,
los últimos términos, o sea este es el último de aquí y este es el último de acá
entonces tenemos que multiplicar
esos 2. Quizás debí haber marcado el amarillo también bueno, entonces los rojos son los últimos 2,
que es menos raíz de 6 por raíz de 2 que ya vimos acá arriba que es menos
menos raíz de 12, y si te das cuenta que da exactamente lo mismo que acá
¿Verdad? Bueno estos dos quedan cambiados pero es exactamente la misma expresión,
y por lo tanto después de eso ya puedes
simplificarla a esta expresión, que ya
encontramos. Entonces está bien usarlo y también te da la respuesta correcta
pero hay que tener en cuenta que este método que es un algorítmo
simplemente viene de aplicar
la propiedad distributiva 2 veces.